how did Tom Hardy do the Blaine voice
and found a character a gentleman called
a gentleman a man called Bartley Gorman
who's a romanly gypsy and the king of
the gypsies in inverted commas and a
bare knuckle fighter and a boxer and uh
he said would I go into a ring with him
and he wanted to wipe me off the fish
and yuck and nobody wants to kill me I
was like oh this is great and then I was
like I showed Chris I said Chris we can
either go down a
sort of sort of Darth Vader kind of
route and you know straight you know
just neutral toned villain voice
or we could try this and this I've been
thinking of just in case we you know we
we you know we've got to consider the
roots and origins of the of the Bane but
we could get laughed out the part with
it it might be something that we regret
but it's your choice ultimately because
no I think we'll go with it that was
that well we played with it and made it
a bit more fluorid and uh and now people
love it